foreign
[Music]
car
Audrey oh my God that was so good you're
such a big shot you are the big shot you
big shot lawyer best friends reunited
[Music]
deep in the night how I wonder
please make him real how I'll pray
what that was so lame what was that no
you cat and I were part of the same
College acapella group The toodles
hello it's so nice to see you I'm I hear
that you're living in Audrey's garage
and and drawing penises now uh I told
you Lolo is an amazing artist I do body
positive art and remind me of your name
again my legal name is Vanessa call me
dead eye
where did that come from
you know I think I get it again I think
God
every day it's bringing us together
oh are you doing Bible Thumpers
oh I I have always been a woman of God I
mean remember that was one of the first
things I told you when we met right
Audrey that
I am a good Christian girl saving myself
for marriage wait wait wait wait wait
you too
have never had sex our connection is
based on spiritual not physical intimacy
did you have a spiritual connection when
the Jonas brothers were Eiffel towering
you
oh my God that's so funny I love Paris
right I gotta go good you need anything
[Music]
there's some room for Jesus
I don't think I've ever been around only
Asian people I mean
we look like everyone else for once I
think we blend right in yeah but people
here can tell Chinese Chinese from
American Chinese what do you mean Hong
Kong pennies Bluetooth
Shanghai Chinese bougie
Taiwanese weird but cute what kind of
Chinese are they
what for you you're trying to get
canceled those are Koreans oh that's how
they find it's a K-pop group yeah they
all have the same face that's how you
can tell
how do you come up with this stuff I
just want people to be more body
positive you know sex isn't shameful
it's beautiful like the noises yeah come
on
[Laughter]
this is a drinking game
what are the rules
[Applause]
you ready to lose your celebrity oh I
can't wait to slap the [__] out of you
I think so
oh
okay
look at that once more
Audrey you and me you and me let's
[__] go
what was this [__] deal
that's my [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
are you sure this is gonna work
BTS Army always comes through at
ginderella 88 so we should be good to go
our confident we're brownie Tuesday
we're a brand new group we just did our
debut in Shanghai our first single has
nine million downloads everyone remember
their names sassy Lisa two we got this
we got this
best friend's trip this is gonna be
iconic
you do understand this is a work trip
for me Audrey I got you look at me
you're thinking about a dick damn it
you're right
Adventure I heard that if you keep up
they respect you more
listen up listen up listen up
you got a plug are you gonna play is it
a condom you look like you've had a lot
of things in your [__] I'm not a lot
of things just one thing but many
different varieties of that one thing
you're a fan up there like a claw
machine trying to get the stuffed bear
yeah
if you do not know where you come from
how do you know who you are I'm just a
garbage American who only speaks English
and a little Golem
en
do you guys have that here yeah we have
it's all over the world
be adults are you horny
sex isn't shameful it's beautiful like
the noises oh
look
show them there's some boards in this
house there's some [__] in this house
I'm not racist you don't like Boba and
you never [__] an Asian guy damn still
when I masturbate I sometimes fantasize
about Splinter he's Asian he's a rat
he's a good father
[Music]